right great five four three and that to
one what is up everyone welcome to
simulation we are seeing down stirling
ljubljana thanks for coming on the show
yes sir thanks for having me well
appreciated no problem glad to be here
all the way from Texas yep all the way
from Texas indeed sir
yeah we'll hear a little bit of that
accident oh you're definitely gonna get
some accent action for sure we've got a
communications ambassador for Bitcoin
comm boom
yep that is my current role with Bitcoin
comm and it's been a lot of fun a lot of
traveling a lot of seeing the world and
a lot of getting people on board with
Bitcoin cash and letting them know the
principles of freedom
you just had to throw in that last vid
in there I like that little I don't know
the principles of freedom
okay you got to unpack that for us can't
just sprinkle that on and be like oh
they're not gonna ask me about that one
right how is cryptocurrency and
blockchain how is that the principles of
freedom yeah this is an interesting
discussion because there's a lot of
people coming into the cryptocurrency
space right now a lot of capital
investment firms and a lot of
entrepreneurs developers etc who may not
have an understanding of the background
of where cryptocurrency comes from so
let's start with step one a step one is
strictly philosophical so there's this
idea of anarchism which just means
without rulers it means that human
relationship should be as consensual as
far as humanly possible and this
original idea of anarchism was really
developed and teased apart and fleshed
out in mainland Europe and it was
strictly more of a leftist and communist
based idea where it was all about the
workers workers rights and those kind of
things well as the these ideas got
imported into America a new version of
anarchism started to crop up and it's
this idea
individualist anarchism or a voluntary
ISM and the person responsible for
really laying down these principles and
these ideas
his name's Murray Rothbard rothbard was
a great academic little lot of fantastic
books so one of the books that I like
talking about a lot that he wrote was
called for a new Liberty for a new
Liberty is a book that outlines the idea
that voluntary ISM or the idea that all
human relationships should be
consensually or should happen on a
consensual basis is of utmost importance
and value but he also talked about the
importance of self ownership and
ownership over our property and
potential can be a simplified down to
just yes and yes they already saying yes
that that's right both parties agreeing
to whatever actions or contracts that
they engage in and that's how those
relationships should function but
Rothbart's book for new Liberty laid
down these principles and we could live
in an anarchist society if everything
was completely consensual right well if
people agreed that instead of relying on
governments or like relying on
institutions to compel people to behave
in a certain way in that situation
people would come to contractual
arrangements with each other to
determine how society should function
and how society should run this is a
good behavior incentivization yeah
absolutely that's what it's that's what
it's all about essentially is a sin
incentivizing certain kinds of behavior
that is based on people simply
cooperating and getting along
governments are antithetical to the
ethic of cooperating of cooperation so
it's never gonna be a situation that
crops up with it with a government with
government that allows for complete
cooperation and individuals being able
to work together peaceably because
everything that government does is
interjected with the force of a gun
right with somebody saying you're going
to do this via some regulation law rule
or dictum that you have to follow these
precepts or else we're going to hurt you
we're going to throw you in a
cage we're going to put you on some kind
of probationary measure it's gonna be
some type of pain or suffering they
endure but wait we can get to that I
really want to dive into how this
anarchist philosophy really merged into
the digital realm as you mentioned
talked about Bitcoin and blockchain how
it moved that direction so rothbard came
up with these ideas as I mentioned and
then in the early 90s there were a group
of digital Desperados who lived in this
area the San Francisco Bay Area and also
Silicon Valley Santa Clara etc and they
were referred to as the cypherpunks so
the cypherpunks had this idea that we
should be able to use digital
technologies to regain this power of
anonymity of freedom of privacy and to
use these principles to literally
undermine the state or to get outside
the scope of the state because and
remember this was in the early 90s the
internet was in its infancy right it was
just being birthed and we didn't even
know all the possibilities we didn't
know how it would begin to grow and
change society as we understand it so
these folks were already ahead of time
they had an idea that governments would
try to get more and more and more
involved with people's communication
online now here's the connecting point
between anarchism and the digital world
these cypherpunks namely Timothy Mae who
is sort of the ringleader who was sort
of involved deeply in this movement he
came up with an idea known as crypto
anarchism essentially he wrote the first
crypto anarchist manifesto I know I say
manifesto it sounds like it's gonna be
like a twenty billion pages of work and
it's gonna be dense not three or four
paragraphs and you can read the whole
thing but the idea is just the way I
outlined it it's about anonymity using
technology for anonymity for freedom for
privacy for getting outside the scope of
the state in all matters and there was
another cyberpunk you just see cuz I
want to keep playing on on what you're
where you're going here did you see the
recent video that was circulated about
those
classroom management systems in China I
did not see that a computer vision
facial recognition on every single
student in the classroom washing their
emotions watching classifying their
emotions watching how many times they
raise their hand counting attendance
counting compliance and so this is it's
kind of you give you gave that face of
that and and I just I want to I want to
see this is kind of the exact opposite
of what you're saying so I would say so
yeah it's pretty pretty brutal yeah so
okay so then on this one side is this
massive Big Brother governmental
oversight to ensure compliance and to
ensure safety and to ensure high quality
of social compliance and then on the
other side of things is the consensual
not voluntary anarchism completely
consensual
we can ask Youmans figure out how to
engage with each other without the need
for a massive governmental oversight to
ensure that we can do that ourselves and
this seems to be part of the cypherpunk
and the crypto anarchist yeah so so
really the the ethic the guiding ethic
behind what a cyber Punk is and what a
cyber Punk does is this notion that all
relationship should be consensual as far
as humanly possible and obviously having
a surveillance police state where all
your actions are monitored and
surveilled is not in line with
consensual activity unless someone just
loves being a slave and they want to go
up to their master and say will you
please monitor every action that I want
to take as I move through life yeah that
would be you know that would be their
own idea and that would be fair but most
people I don't think want to be
monitored follow they don't wanna have
all their data intercepted and spied on
so what happens with bad actors so this
is a question we get really deep into
the weeds of how society can sort of and
people can solve problems that we would
recall disagreements right so
a bad actor of somebody who most people
would disagree with because maybe they
want to harm another person so we'll use
that just an example of murder right so
if somebody kills another person that
would be considered a bad actor in
generally traditionally in the statist
environment the government would come in
and they would you know there was cops
and arrest that person and they would go
through the criminal justice system and
then yeah it effectively thrown into
prison so how that these problems have
to be solved in a market environment is
using and here's one idea that's been
proposed by a lot of anarcho-capitalists
using private defense agencies or
private security agencies to first make
sure that these situations don't awry
arise to begin with and that's by not
being violent and aggressive to start
with because a lot of times the police
force as it is and we can see this in
the United States - the very aggressive
pre-emptive and actually ends up being
the perpetrator of harm over a myriad of
people and to give you provide an
example how our private defense agency
would work in in real time like in real
life right now we have examples so in
Detroit and many people may not know
this but Detroit is a city that has
basically lost its governance right it's
fallen into bankruptcy and there is not
as much of a police presence in Detroit
even to this day so around 15 or 20
years already a company emerged called
Detroit threat management it used to be
called Vipers threat management and this
is a private defense agency that is
charged with the task privately of
helping defend the citizenry and defend
the businesses and the the awesome thing
about this agency is that they boast no
loss of life no casualties you can't
really say that for any American police
department usually somebody's gonna die
well you know a lot of times so we've
seen people die when please come out to
a situation that just gets escalated so
these guys focus on human psychology
about de-escalating certain kinds of
situations and making sure that instead
of actually having a criminal
they negate that activity and they use a
lot of psychology to do that now of
course they're still going to be the
potential that somebody does harm
another person in society that the
private defense agency isn't able to
take care of defending or creating a
situation that arises of that so what
you have to do I like to use the example
of a Gaelic Ireland they had a really a
libertarian community of this Gaelic
Harlan lasted for 2,000 years but
effectively if somebody harmed another
person instead of the society seeing
that as a criminal act against the state
instead they saw it as a person who
perpetrated an act of harm against
another individual and in the case of
murder of course the the victim isn't
there to defend themselves so the family
comes in and they appeal to these
private judges to see about handling
that situation how reparation should be
made and if the person decides to go
into that to go to court then it would
be resolved in that manner with judges
called Bree Hans and this is just an
example of a way we could potentially
deal with this in the modern age it
wouldn't work out in the same exact way
because we don't really have tribal
factions like they did in Gaelic Ireland
but that's one method of how to handle
it and if the person of course the the
person who did the bad deed who murdered
the other person or aggressed against
somebody could say nope I'm not going to
court not going to deal with this I
didn't do anything wrong in Gaelic
Ireland that was effectively a sentence
of exile so if they didn't want to deal
with the problem then they were exiled
from that society now they could stay in
society but it would get bloody at that
point because that would basically put
that mark on that person that they are
just free game for anybody just to kill
so that's not a proper solution I think
we would consider valid for the modern
error because you know first of all how
housing there's principles across
history as well as even today that are
implemented like this private police
force in Detroit the deed escalating
situations right and
there's these different variables that
we can potentially push together and
different processes that can actually
make voluntary re-enter keys I'm
actually something possible yeah that's
exactly what I'm gonna add here that
let's let's talk about how that looks it
seems to be that it looks a lot like a
decentralized and distributed technology
something similar to a blockchain
something similar to a way for people to
be held accountable for their actions
but not with massive governmental
oversight so you can't go and kill
somebody but you sure as hell want to be
consensual with every single person with
every single action however this ends up
occurring is it's very interesting and I
want to see a test that I want to see it
put to practice right yeah absolutely
the beautiful thing about this this idea
of decentralized governance which
effectively is will be anarchism or at
least in some jurisdictions be in arc
ism is that it's already getting or
being prepared to be tested in various
places so there's this really brilliant
idea in one jurisdiction called Libre
land Libre land is this basically free
country that's in Europe I forget all of
the countries that it borders but it's
going it's there in the process it's a
difficult situation because they haven't
been able to get it up and running yet
because they're having some problems
from neighboring governments allowing
them to have the free rein jurisdiction
or to have it act as a free economic
zone where people can experiment with
different forms of governance but the
idea that they're planning is that this
is going to be a more libertarian
Society and it's going to be it's going
to have rules right that's one of the
concerns people have about anarchism
it's not gonna have any rules well I
want to clarify also that anarchism
literally just means without rulers
without people telling you how to live
and using coercion to force those that
lifestyle upon you so in liebherr land
the idea is that people come in to live
they sign a contract that has the rules
laid out
but here's the key they're voluntary and
we talked about this is really important
they're voluntarily opting in to engage
with people in the society in the ways
that are outlined so if they do wrong
there's going to be some private defense
agency or even some kind of private
police force that handles those problems
but the beautiful thing is is that they
agreed to live that way with those
people and this is a real contract and
this is juxtaposed with this idea of a
social contract and that's what we live
under currently and in modern society
but the problem we have a social
contract right now between each other
that we're not going to beat each other
up right the who who would contract
there right is Erica because we are
still beating people up right that you
know that's a great question that see
this is the thing with the social
contract it the truth is it's not really
a contract its social contract is just a
dictate by a government in a
principality that says that because
you're born here you have to live under
the rules of this jurisdiction or we're
gonna come out and harm you an actual
contract implies that you and I Alan we
sat down and we laid out you know maybe
some paperwork and we determined that
one of us wants to engage by the rules
of this contract social contract in this
instance isn't a contract it's a dictate
or a mandate that compels somebody to
live a certain way so the idea of a
social contract is really a misnomer in
this context okay because there's a
top-down hierarchical command for us to
not hurt one another not necessarily you
and I agreeing to one another that we
wouldn't hurt each other that yes that's
a that's a great way to characterize it
so there's some entity or organization
or body of men and just to be clear I
want to define government so any
individuals who are watching this have a
clear understanding a government is just
a group of men who have a monopoly on
the initiative
a force over a large territorial region
and that's a more accurate definition of
what a government ism and that
particular definition was used by Murray
Rothbard and a lot of the Austrian
economists as they sort of analyzed and
tried to tease apart what what a state
or what a government actually is a group
of people who have force over an area of
land
yeah the monopoly on the initiation of
force over a large territorial region
and and and that's what we're dealing
with and as far as governance is
concerned there's just a simple group of
people just like us what everybody would
do if they were in any position of power
and based on their their belief
structure what they believe is right and
wrong right right
well I yeah people individuals have
their own idea of right and wrong of
morality of decency and dignity but they
can't ever or can't always exercise
their beliefs in right and wrong if a
government is determining the action
that they have to take in that case they
are compelled to live a certain way and
a great example of this is the drug war
for instance web I think that you and
Alan we probably agree that the drug war
has been a catastrophic failure and it's
been a failure because of the social
contract the idea that you're born in
this place you have to live in this
place and governments tell you that
drugs are wrong and they create a
plethora of laws that are practically
incomprehensible because they're so long
and so full but they contain information
about a ton of these drugs and how awful
and nasty they are and many of them are
consciousness expanding and yet bingo
many of them will actually help heal us
or help put us in a state of mind that
allows us to introspect and to come to
terms with who they are but governments
effectively don't want people to be able
to do that they want to crush people's
soul they want to render people helpless
and a nerd right so they you think
that's the principle that it was built
on in 1776
we didn't have the drugs that we had in
1776 that right yeah the what they had
cannabis yeah it seems to be though that
back then the idea wasn't to crush the
soul of people it was more so to provide
a ten basic principles and following
these would ensure you good life look at
our Constitution what are we right in it
why is the Bill of Rights important why
is the way that we expanded across the
u.s. important did we hurt people along
the way yes yeah do we now have sheet
sea to shining sea yes is that important
for us to be a geopolitical leader today
yes is are we one of the last pillars of
democracy on the planet
yes Europe our counterparts isn't as
strong of an economy as we are there's
there's lots of reason why the earth is
not owned by Hitler or owned by
communist Russia or China there's a lot
of reason why the earth is still the way
it is and it's because the US was able
to do what it had done from those
principles onward so I'm also very
grateful for those principles and
grateful for the governance that we've
had up until this point now is
decentralization the next step and could
it become something that ends up
proliferating across the planet as
something that's decentralized
propelling the we are one propelling the
consensual agreements we'd love to see
that right yeah absolutely and I want to
say first off you know with what you
mentioned about this early experiment in
the United States with a constitutional
republic
I think the founders and this is clear
in their writings their intention was to
actually create an opportunity for
people to be free especially as it
concerns religion the people in in
Britain were escaping extreme and severe
religious persecution where they
couldn't practice their
with any kind of freedom or they would
literally be executed or harmed in some
manner so I think their intentions and
their motives were pure in that regard
but what this experiment taught us was
that a government cannot be contained
you know Lord Acton had that really
famous quote absolute power corrupts
absolutely so when you create a vacuum
of power it tends to expand beyond
control and that's exactly what happened
in the United States of power of
individuals with power can find a way to
expand their field of influence they're
going to do that and it's often been
said that you know we really have this
mentality of worshipping the
constitution of appreciating the
Constitution for what it does to protect
our rights but the problem we've noticed
with the Constitution is that I can't
stop bullets it can't stop cops from
locking people up and throwing them in a
cage what's happened literally is it's
become a living document and a lot of
people tout that as a very important
component of what a constitution is but
what actually ends up happening with a
living document is judges can interpret
it in any way they want to as
effectively giving them the power to
make a final judgment on what happens to
an individual in the court of law which
is an unfortunate side effect of rampant
statism that we're experiencing right
now but to your point about this next
step which i think is utterly and
extremely important we are now moving
into territory where we have the
resources where we have the value where
we have the technology to begin
experimenting with different forms of
self-governance
so that we won't have to rely on
centralization and centralized power
structures to control us and to oversee
us and to make sure that society
functions now we can write the rules
into a blockchain and we can infuse that
blockchain with artificial intelligence
with various ways to control itself to
grow to iterate to create a structured
society that people can voluntarily
opt-in and I mentioned Libre land but
this isn't just happening in Libre land
that's one we like about so many
examples today at the blocking for
social justice conference
there were so many who they were like Oh
an Amsterdam we're testing in the seeded
cities right now what it's like one
rather than depending on the corporate
hierarchy to deliver you food or a tool
that you need when you need it we'll
just get you a very quick delivery of
the same price from a local business and
then over time the community will become
so much tighter and the velocity of
money will be moving so much faster and
you'll be able to build up that
community in a way that will flourish to
a better extent you just basically you
you you you cut off the necessity to
rely on the Amazon or the Alibaba and
that changes things tremendously not
saying that we all have to all of a
sudden stop ordering from Amazon and
only use local business but when we
figure out how to make the local
business completely the same or close to
the same price and close to the same
speed I think it's actually really
important and can ask convenient I think
is really important to figure out how to
thrive in the community that you live in
and do things like have a direct
communication elana between other people
in your community and then the
leadership in that community that's the
way that seems to be like such a massive
way forward and I'm just really happy
that that's like directly relates to how
you're describing the the civilization
2.0 oh yeah man I'm so excited that you
mentioned that I'm really stoked about
this particular topic and impassioned
about it because I think what's really
going on is that we're in some ways
returning to a more primitive state of
nature and I don't mean primitive
technologically but I mean primitive in
the sense that we're gonna be more
reliant on our inner networks you know
what is it the the Dunbar number
mentions the number of connections that
a human can maintain in a society where
those relationships really revolve
around bonding interpersonal
communication connection compassion
empathy all those good butyl
things that make us human that really
make us human
but blockchain technology the
technologies that we're dealing with are
really what are what's helping to
facilitate this more this return to a
more communitarian environment I mean
listen the situation with governments
right now in any centralized entity is
that some individual who lives thousands
of miles away from you who wears a suit
and tie to work every day with an
American flag a pin on his lapel is
essentially telling businesses how to
run their businesses how to distribute
their goods between society via
regulations of business corporate taxes
those kind of things but also telling
the individual thousands of miles away
just to imagine this a person that
you've never met before that you've
never had interpersonal contact with
before telling you that they know what's
best for you and your life but this
technology really inverts that whole
process turns it back around to the
individual communities to make their own
decisions because we have the
technological acumen now to actually
make that happen that we have the the
adroit nests and deafness of hand to
allow technology to grow and flourish in
a communitarian environment which
actually invites more connections
between people more empathy between
people more concern about others and
that's really what the modern age is all
about that's what this technological
revolution is all about it's about
making those connections and being with
people it's part of what the human
leisure time should be about I think
what it is about and I think with some
pieces of the Industrial Revolution some
pieces of too much government
involvement has caused us to forget that
but now in a way or coming back to this
state of nature and one of my favorite
writers and authors talked about this in
a different kind of way a Terence
Mckenna who is a great psychedelic
pioneer mentioned this notion of the
archaic revival this return to this the
state of nature where we were more
closely connected to each other but
inherent and Terrance's vision he he did
mention the importance of technology and
the role of bringing us back to the
state but interestingly enough it's also
a step forward into the future because
it
it's a reminder of our roots of who we
are as human beings and where we're
going it's a really a beautiful poetic
sentiment
I am also extremely happy to care about
this so much yeah and you speak about it
with a lot of passion I love that I
wonder what it's gonna be like the
rebirth back into the nature into the
communities and how we're gonna leverage
technology in order to help us get there
I wonder how many of the company execs
are thinking about this as like an
actual Oh God
maybe decentralization and maybe the
community figuring out how to rely on
each other and build really strong
connections between one another I wonder
how many of them are slightly concerned
about that or if it's maybe the natural
trajectory of just decentralizing away
from their money and back to everybody
right you know funny thing about that
consideration is I can't speak for like
the CEO of Walmart or Target or anything
you know in the retail sector like that
but I can't speak for the quasi
decentralized sector
I was recently watching a video with
Brian Chesky who is the CEO of Airbnb
and in this talk the very articulate guy
and he was discussing this notion of
humans starting to connect with each
other more as people who don't
necessarily have knowledge or first-hand
experience with one another and this is
part of this reputation economy
revolution that we're entering into and
that's what their business is all about
Airbnb you're actually having to trust
another person to share your space with
them if you're if you host a private
room on Airbnb you're bringing people
into your vicinity that doesn't
necessarily mean they're within your
community directly they could be
travelers from elsewhere but this is
already about not just for the expedited
process of having a place to stay it's
also about sharing the experience of
that space with another person and that
also facilitates the bonding process
that brings us together as humans and is
also in line with
notion of the archaic revival of
returning back to this this sort of
jubilant state of nature that these
folks talked about but that's what these
discussions of course are already
happening happening in the upper echelon
of businesses especially in the quasi
decentralized sector Chesky spent a
whole discussion talking about that but
I guess he kind of has to since his
business is focused on the way that
people interact with each other in the
spaces that they call their personal
homes etc so I can only imagine that
this topic is gonna start to loom large
as more and more decentralized
technologies especially decentralized
versions of the ride-sharing services
start to crop up more Airbnb ease that
are based on algorithms or blockchains
that get outside the scope of having
central those businesses still have
centralized headquarters what's the
difference between having the
centralization of the United States
currency versus the centralization of
Bitcoin com right that's actually a good
question and I may we may take this one
a little bit of a different direction
but and just talk about cryptocurrency
specifically rather than are are coming
our company is decentralized but it's
that's another interesting topic okay so
the big issue with governments and their
partnership with the banks which forms
like a quasi banking cartel is that they
actually have ultimate control and
ultimate power to print as much money
and as much currency as possible and put
that currency into circulation now
anybody who studied just a tad bit of
history and just a tad bit of economics
knows that governments cannot be trusted
central banks cannot be trusted to
handle this amount of power this ability
to print as much money as they want to
we can look all over the world for
examples in the problems with inflation
for anybody who doesn't know or hasn't
studied economics inflation is just the
idea of printing out money and then once
you print out that money if you print
out a whole bunch of it it devalues the
purchasing power of that money and
causes
the price of goods and services in a
jurisdiction to rise you print too much
money and effectively devalues the money
so much that all it's good for is
kindling by the night by the bedside
fire of the family and this has happened
in places like Venezuela it's happened
in places to some degree in Ecuador a
lot of places in South America
sub-saharan Africa a lot of places have
devalued their currency to such an
extreme amount that it's absolutely
useless so this is the effectively the
problem with centralization when you
centralize any kind of institution
especially in finance and you have to
rely on these small group of individuals
and effectively trust them what happens
is you take a risk of them not making
the right decisions and actually harming
society and yourself personally in the
process now with a decentralized
technology or a decentralized route or
or a decentralized company instead of
having the control centralized in a
group of individuals instead it's
distributed or dispersed among a whole
vast swath of the population with
cryptocurrency it's actually distributed
globally with some caveat that there is
been a little bit more centralization as
a result of the mining process with
cryptocurrency but the beautiful thing
about this decentralization process is
that it's based on a protocol and an
algorithm that determines how much
currency this is specifically the
currency example how much of it can
actually be printed out or created over
time so in the case of Bitcoin 21
million units is the precise amount that
will ever be created and that's the what
we call the cap limit and by the year
2140 all of the bitcoins will be put
into circulation and this is determined
by the rules of this network
decentralized system but it sounds like
we're back to you know if we it just
sounds like we're back to square one if
there's only like it's all about who
gets all those 21 million bitcoins
right well yeah I'll definitely address
that I just want to say this when you
rely on a centralized group of
individuals to print out as much of the
currency as they want to then you're
going to have problems there's going to
be social turmoil as a result of
inflation and nobody's going to be able
to connect with each other now the
problem that you pointed out with
cryptocurrency Bitcoin is definitely a
valid concern when all of its printed
out now you have all this a ton of
cryptocurrency in existence one of the
really sweet things about cryptocurrency
that's really clever is that even if
people start to hoard it that's what I
understand you're coming from there's
gonna be this problem and maybe some
really greedy people hoarding all that
cryptocurrency and holding it totally
legitimate problem cryptocurrency solves
that because it's divisible to the
millionth decimal point right you can
break down cryptocurrency as many times
as almost as many times as you want and
what when you do that it heightens the
value of the smaller fractional units of
cryptocurrency so even though someone's
holding a bunch of it your lesser pieces
become more valuable as a result of that
scarcity that's been created so it
mitigates that nasty effect that some
people may be more greedy and malicious
as a result and that is impossible with
centralized fiat currency controls like
the Federal Reserve System because you
can't break down a dollar you know you
only break down a dollar into quarters
dimes and pennies right you can't break
a fiat currency I did say I was just
talking about the bar and explained I I
don't know what that is
sure so anybody if fiat currency is it
literally means by decree right it's
writ by decree that this is legal tender
that's why it's called fiat because
governments decree it and suggest that
people have to use it in society on
threat of violence against them the
stuff we were talking about earlier with
government cryptocurrency wouldn't be
fiat currency because it's not by decree
it's being created by a group of miners
that people can voluntarily -
to use or not hints weathers now
competing cryptocurrencies a myriad of
cryptocurrencies that everybody can get
involved in and use so fiat currency
literally means by decree by force etc
there's still something that doesn't
fully check out about the limited amount
of tokens that go out because even
though that that becomes a deflationary
currency rather than inflationary
currency that even then once you get to
the divisible amounts of 1000 or 1
million per Bitcoin even then there's
just something that doesn't check out
about someone or a bunch of people kind
of reminds me actually of the 51%
problem as well and mining and just
changing the direction of all of the
blockchain so just something about it
still doesn't fully click for me there's
there's something about these units of
exchange I guess for a temporary
solution it makes sense but there's an
upgraded version that we still haven't
thought of and I'm really interested in
what that upgraded version is right sure
so I don't even know how long it'll be
around then in that case uh-huh right so
your can your concern laughs was like
it's gonna be alright
I I think yeah I think a lot of you know
not every crypt there's a lot of
cryptocurrencies now right easily over a
thousand you can go to coin market cap
and see just a ton of them most of them
are just IC o---- scam coins and [ __ ]
coins that are definitely not gonna be
around because they're in their intent
as as a pump and dump scheme but to your
point I guess your main concern is that
the crypto currencies are still going to
be somehow become centralized or taken
over by it
the are centralized of individuals they
are I mean there's just no way around
that you can't right now explain to
anybody that aetherium or Bitcoin or
litecoin or any of these other coins are
completely
centralise because they're not it was a
group of developers that still manages
the blockchain that the coins run on
right well I'm not disagreeing with you
that's true but it's only true for some
cryptocurrencies or more true for some
cryptocurrencies and not as true for
other ones so here's the big issue with
that in its really a lot of people in
our industry and this ecosystem
currently tapped out the importance of
decentralization and definitely the more
decentralization we have the better but
that's not actually the feature or the
quality that we really really care about
what we really care about is this notion
of having a currency that's censorship
resistant meaning that I can send it
from me to you in a peer-to-peer fashion
nobody can seize that transaction freeze
that transaction stop that transaction
and if we're engaging in that kind of
transaction that where the message can't
be held and stopped then we're dealing
with a situation where we have enough
decentralization to validate the the
mild amount of centralization that has
cropped up so in the grand scheme of
things having a tad bit of
centralization is not a problem now
let's talk about that a bit more let's
dive into the situation with mining
centralization and look at the the
problems there I do agree that mining
centralization is a problem that needs
to be looked at and examined but I do
think the problem is also overstated a
bit there is problems with a 51% attack
don't get me wrong if there are certain
coins that are they have really weak a
hash rate that are more gonna be more
affected by 51% attack or an attacker
may feel like it's okay to go ahead and
attack this coin because it's still
young and I have more to gain from
conducting an attack on networks like
Bitcoin or even Bitcoin cash or
aetherium these kind of 51 percent
attacks even if that they're able to
conduct them just assuming there's a
group of miners who controls 51 percent
of the network you have to ask the
question is that profitable for them to
make that attack is are they going to be
incentivized to conduct that attack in
most cases they're actually not because
if they run the risk of attacking that
network
a 51% attack and then doing some double
spins or defrauding the network in some
way if by accident they destroy that
network will they've lost all their
profitability as a minor right they're
making an extreme buku amount of money
simply from conducting the proof-of-work
activity that's necessary to validate
the network and if they compromise that
by trying to cheat the network well they
may have compromised their own income so
you have to ask the question is it
profitable for an organization even if
they have 51% of the network to
undermine it now yes there's a lot of
guesswork and there's a lot of variables
that go it could get involved in this
but recently we had a 51% attack on the
Xen cash network and there was another
network that had an attack but because
of the young nature in the in the price
for mining those particular coins
it was clearly more profitable for
though for attacks to be conducted on
them that those networks but one of the
cool things about it is even though
those networks were attacked it wasn't
like a permanent attack that just
completely destroyed the network the
developers just had to figure out a way
to strengthen their network and make it
work where there won't be any 51%
attacks because if they don't well then
that cryptocurrency is gonna die and go
out of fashion's in cash to my knowledge
is still running still going strong so
so there's this there's this you can
agree to have a small amount of
centralization in favor of a vast amount
of decentralization I want to be able to
engage with you without a third party
consensually and that is worth a small
amount of central you know for now until
we figure out what's better than this
and I'm so in love with the transition
right now it's great but I'm still very
in love with the genius of what it will
be with complete decentralisation and
I'm just always trying to figure out
what it will be in that sense for
everything across financial transactions
across voting across ownership
biometrics everything and and then
there's the what happens after money
what's post money because then what's
post money is it's still money it's
still value it's still economy post
money you know this is a that's a great
question
but it's still money right yeah and
let's let's get into that I want to do
address something that you mentioned
first that I think is very important
because I agree with you that we will
probably move beyond doing doing the
proof of work I think some a lot of
cryptocurrencies are starting to mix a
variety of consensus mechanisms and a
variety of ways to validate and verify
the network maintain the network without
just using strictly proof of work
because there's some other problems with
that besides the problem of mining
becoming an arms race there's also an
issue of power consumption that's gonna
eventually be a concern granted the you
know a lot of people have that criticism
but honestly the Visa and MasterCard
networks consume probably quadruple the
amount of energy and we've written about
this on news Bitcoin calm anybody can go
check it out but the those networks the
legacy financial system consumers way
more energy than the Bitcoin
cryptocurrency networks all combined
with that said I think we're gonna move
into a legacy financial consumes more
than all of the their entities easily
easily imagine all the money that's
being produced all the trees that have
to be cut down all the office buildings
that are running the networks all the
middlemen who are using electricity and
power it's and that's globally these
mining networks aren't even they don't
have a global presence yet and if they
do exist they're actually running a lot
more I'll say cleanly because there's
the say they exist in Iceland a lot of
mining operations are in Iceland because
they simply plug their miner into a
volcano and gain essentially geothermal
energy to power that operation and you
can't even give away geothermal energy
there's so much of it so that's one way
to start looking at that solution but to
really dig into the to the weeds of the
future here what I really love about
this is we're gonna start seeing
blockchains crop
that use a mixture of proof of work and
that use proof of stake and/or delegated
proof of stake these are just a few
options that we have on the plate right
now but these Mehcad mechanisms first of
all they don't require the arms race of
mining there are still some miners but
they rely on more on chain governance
models more democratized ways of working
on chain to figure out how to scale how
to grow a blockchain and also how to
make sure that different people have
access to different forms of value now
just for anybody doesn't know proof of
state means that you can you help verify
and maintain the network by holding a
stake of those tokens the more tokens
you have the more work that you can do
to verify the network and the more money
that you can make just as an example
etherium is looking at moving on to
having a also be proof of stake along
with proof of work and this is what's
been called the Casper protocol built
into aetherium another option is
delegated proof of stake which I really
enjoy it's this idea that a person has
stake on the platform and then they can
effectively point to another actor in
that ecosystem and delegate blockchain
rewards basically the cryptocurrency
that's produced by that blockchain to
another person in practice this works
like this so there's a platform called
steam it the steam blogging platform
where people write blogs and it's like a
riddle
ooh that's our 15-minute timer you don't
have to ask me that hourglass on to your
left it's on the table sure thank you
sure awesome how we go I will conclude
this point so steam it essentially works
like Reddit you upvote content and then
it on reddit though it just your post
can catch fire and more people about it
and it has more visibility on Steam it
you a person who up votes if they have
stake in the steam at platform they
delegate the blockchain reward to that
post so it's a way of being able to
reward content creators as a person who
has stake in a platform so you basically
have influence in that platform with
them the money you have
but you're not problem with just proof
of stake is that you can get you know
filthy rich by just holding a bunch of
coins and a lot of people have created
scams by just having proof of
state-based coins where they can just
have the first amount of coins that are
printed and then they can run a pump and
dump scheme by hyping up that coin and
they've got all the money and they just
get more the more people get in so it
really is a pyramid type of scheme and
then they can just dump it all and
that's happened a multitude of times
what in the ecosystem is so so the
future is currently lots of
decentralization little bit of
centralization okay and then pass that
we'll see what happens like you see gave
a bunch of good examples of kind of
what's going on what's post money
let's do quick power power round because
I we got a bunch of questions of sorta -
so alright so I think we're this is an
interesting first let's talk about what
is money right I think before we can
talk about post money was talk about
post or it was talk about what money is
real quick
Andres Antonopoulos I like his
definition or idea of what money is and
really money is value so the problem
with value is that it's subjective we
each have sort of a subjective mindset
as to what constitutes value and because
of that really money's just a collective
hallucination we just all imagined it to
have value so money is just our ability
to transfer and to communicate value to
each other so I like to think of money
as a form of communication and if we
think of money like that it's not really
possible to go into a month post money
Society in some form of fashion we're
going to be communicating value to one
another and if you really think about it
blockchain is kind of post money because
you're not dealing you know the idea of
having a token or a coin is misleading
what if we disassociate ourselves from
the conversation of value what if when
we think about producing something it
doesn't actually preclude anyone else
from producing it so therefore when you
say you want to produce a certain part
of some sort of spaceship that you want
it doesn't preclude anybody else from
doing it and there's no monetary
association to the value of that thing
therefore you're just producing
something
right so then there's no association of
value to it sure yeah I think I get
where you're headed with this I think in
that type of situation you know a lot of
people when they do work they need to be
incentivized for that work right if
you're producing something the hope is
that you get compensated for that work
somehow or another it's that's really
how human behavior functions we have to
feel that we have incentives to be able
to to create to work to live all of that
stuff is very important however to your
point I believe as we look into the
future if we do get into something that
resembles this notion of being post
money it's going to have to do with the
emergence of artificial intelligence and
the provision of more leisure time for
Humanity if we have a situation where we
don't actively have to produce as much
and we can accumulate value outside the
scope of our own conscious via machines
and machine learning machine
technologies that's a way we can get
outside the scope of value because it's
being created for us we're already
entering into a modern situation where
machines are beginning to take certain
kinds of laborious jobs over and that's
creating the leisure time for humankind
to interact with each other to get back
to this idea of having connections and
bonding and being involved within the
scope of the Dunbar number might create
a situation where we detach ourselves
from value but the the issue is that
will continue to crop up if people do
any kind of work unless it's their
absolute passion and not everybody let's
be frank is going to get to follow their
are their dreams and their passions it's
my hope that eventually we get to that
point but some people frankly don't
really have a consideration of what
their passions are anyway maybe that's a
societal problem maybe a personal
problem psychological who knows but the
issue is that when people work when they
conduct some type of labor even if it is
their passion they hope that they get
rare is some type of value in return but
maybe that value doesn't necessarily
have to be money maybe it can be some
other goods some other kind of commodity
but getting outside the realm of value
that's just a slightly different view
here on the kind of the same issue I
think I'm just like a slightly further
ahead in the
in the clock of when artificial
intelligence nanotechnology everything's
going on there's just too much ability
to just manipulate matter to whatever
degree we want doesn't preclude other
people from doing it no cost associated
with it anymore at that point then I
don't think there is something as money
I think at that point then it's just do
whatever you want with your time let
your digital consciousness go do
whatever the [ __ ] it wants well and
we'll see what the hell that looks like
I don't know anything I'm just talking
on my ass and I know I want you to
elaborate with me on that later okay
well I think you're ahead of your time
on a specific understanding of value you
know what we're each worth artificial
intelligence may without a doubt you
know do all these crazy things that we
valued the individual to have at one
point and may do it better write a
better song write a better poem builds a
better bridge and whatnot so it's it's
interesting yeah yeah right so we're
just to move into the next point
maximizing human potential something we
talked about a lot on the show
this seems to be a growing gap in
inequality that's going on the rich are
getting much much much much much much
richer exacerbated by exponential
technology the poor are just slightly
getting more wealthy so what do you
think's going on with that gap and how
does it also relate to globalization how
can we work together across the borders
of the earth to propel us all forward
together
sure I won't dive into the all the
philosophical or my personal
philosophical views on wealth inequality
I don't think there's any kind of moral
issue with just wealth inequality I
think there are some social issues that
can potentially crop up especially along
the lines of psychological problems like
envy and but what matters is how you
gain gained access to that money that's
a problem but notwithstanding that I do
think that we're gonna enter into a
situation where wealth inequality is
going to come going to begin to close
that gaps gonna begin to close anyway
primarily as a result of the emerging
cryptocurrency markets and I think my
personal story is the
testament to this so prior to getting
into the cryptocurrency space I was just
a poor starving college student you know
who has student loans and barely
surviving but then I found this little
platform called steamin which we talked
about and I started writing and typing
on Steam it creating my own value in a
digital universe that's outside the
scope of the financial system that right
there allowed me to take it take control
of my financial destiny and start trying
to at least make myself happier and
eventually quote closed my own personal
gap in that regard so that's been
extremely important and I think that the
continual growth of blockchain
technology especially the killer app of
currency will help more impoverished
people more people who are struggling
gain some footing and here's the key
thing we talked about to find the
problem with the financial system and I
think it's the primary issue with why
there's such a large wealth gap why
there's wealth inequality it's because
people who play the game of the
financial cartel and who's involved in
that system they have more accessibility
to gaining a tremendous amount of wealth
and a lot of times it has to do with
this idea of cronyism where these big
businesses are working together with
maniacs yeah so ok how about we ask you
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world I think the most beautiful thing
in the world are human connections I
think the power of empathy and love and
to solve the differences that we have is
one of the most beautiful things to me
it's one of the reasons that I it's well
for one it's the reason I married my
wife we had such a very strong
connection she's absolutely beautiful
inside and outside because we had that
connection we were able to work together
and to cooperate to move forward into
the future and I think anybody who has
engaged in a strong meaningful
relationship where you get to know
somebody's soul where you get to know
them on a fundamental deep and poetic
level is the crux of human experience
and I can't think of anything more
beautiful it reminds me of that William
Blake poem you're from
with William Blake the English poet who
said to see the world in a grain of sand
and heaven in a wild flower to hold
infinity in the palm of your hands an
eternity in an hour to me that's what
relationships are all about having that
deep entrenched experience of
appreciation mutual respect and love
with another human being
mm-hmm and that extrapolated even past
just one person to as many people as we
can and building enough of a community
to make one pale blue dot actually
prosper collectively without suffering
hopefully absolutely and I think it's
the icing on the cake of everything
we've been talking talking about this
moving back to this more primitive state
of human connectedness where we're not
as isolated and we're not suffering from
consensus trance and we're not failing
at our bonding and our connections with
events and trance that's funny
I think I think I've previously heard
that as you know zombies or like the
being trapped in the hedonic treadmill
these different types of things those
traps yeah I was already gracious
snapping out of the Pro aging trance of
something that he says a lot next
question do you think we're alone in the
cosmos that's a tough one I haven't
thought about that particular question a
lot but my inclination is to say no
we're not alone in the cosmos I can't
say that another life-form in the cosmos
would be a carbon-based life-form
maybe there's my and my psyche own
psychedelic experiences into those
realms have told me that if there's
beings maybe there's beings of light and
of course this is all speculation this
isn't the same without a doubt that
these beings exist but something tells
me that there's some type of other force
in the universe that could be considered
life we can't say that it's carbon-based
maybe so maybe it's some type of
microorganism that exists elsewhere but
I don't know that's a question that I
speculate and think about sometimes but
haven't really delved into but that's my
knee-jerk gut reaction do you think
we're in a simulation you would of
course have to
that question I you know my problem with
the simulation theory which in
scientists some scientists and theorists
futures have also called it brain in the
VAT the height there the feedback loop I
I can't say that we're necessarily in a
simulation one of the problems with
being in a simulation is it sort of
becomes a reductio ad absurdum right
well if we're in a simulation what about
the simulation that created us or the
what created us is that what if that's
in a simulation and then that's in a
simulation and that's in a simulation
where does it potentially end or how can
you find some kind of logical resolution
sure let's say then by saying do you
think there's a designer I'm an atheist
at heart i i i don't believe that there
is a god but a designer sort of a
different more nuanced question than is
there a god i think that that could be a
possibility but i don't i don't put my
cards on that table very often that's
not something that i spend a lot of time
thinking about i think that's in the
realm of metaphysics is there a designer
possibly i don't think i have enough
evidence and knowledge to give a
definitive yes or no to that
but possibility absolutely sterling what
a freaking blast super fallon thank you
so much yeah this was a real blast a
real pleasure treat really appreciate
you coming onto the show
excited to keep in touch continue
building the future together
networking our connections please
continue pushing the good word of
voluntary anarchism to our world it's a
very fascinating concept that many
people don't even have the time to
consider and think about what it would
be like to just be consensual with each
other and not have to look at the top
down force of what we see now with these
intelligence school management systems
that are going on in china exact
opposite also propelling the good word
of cryptocurrency and blockchain
technology getting us there starting in
these communities going really fast
maybe we can get these fast community
connections rolling and build up from
the community and cut off that necessity
of the top-down hierarchical pull really
good conversation super interesting I'm
really excited to continue our
our future relationship so thank you for
coming on to the show absolutely really
appreciate it sir they appreciate it and
you have great enlightening discussion
thank you thank you everyone for tuning
in if you guys had a good time make sure
to give us a comment below with your
thoughts like the video share it with
other people subscribe to the channel
also make sure to create don't just
consume this content so go and make a
video if they go write a blog about it
just go talk to two people about it have
them go talk to two people and all of a
sudden will start a nice avalanche
movement also join us on patreon e to
continue sustaining the studio going to
cool conferences networking with cool
people paying the team because the team
really needs to get paid you heard me
right the team needs to get paid I'm
talking about Ron and alfredo and all
these guys they need to get paid as soon
as possible I'll keep my payout nothing
because lo it lasts the CEO gets paid
the better the company does so much love
to you guys thanks for tuning in thanks
for on thanks Alfredo for being here
today
much love peace